a tower of ash and smoke 12,000 feet
high this is the aftermath of the
eruption of white island taken by a
tourist who'd been standing at the edge
of the crater just half an hour earlier
an unknown number of people are
unaccounted for the volcano erupted at
2:11 p.m. 1 11 a.m. UK time this image
taken ten minutes before on a webcam
shows the tiny figures of people at the
very rim it continues to be an evolving
situation we know that there were a
number of tourists on or around the
island at the time both New Zealanders
and visitors from overseas I know there
will be a huge amount of concern and
anxiety for those who have loved ones on
or around the island at the time and I
can assure them police are doing
everything they can
police believe there were around 50
people on the island when it erupted 23
have been taken from that at this stage
it is too dangerous for police and
rescue services to go to the island
however we continue to assess the
conditions which would allow us to go on
to the island
the island is currently covered in ash
and volcanic material we are taking
expert advice with regards to the safety
of any rescue attempt white island is 30
miles of the shore of New Zealand's
North Island and seven helicopters were
quickly dispatched st. Johns Ambulance
said they believe up to 20 people still
on the island
require medical treatment some of those
already recovered were treated for burns
police said around 30 to 38 people had
traveled to the island from a Royal
Caribbean cruise ship cultivation of the
Seas the volcano is a popular tourist
spot and I had experienced increased
volcanic activity in the weeks leading
up to today's eruption the government
scientist said this was not a
particularly big eruption more of
prickly
but such was the volcano's power that
even that has proved deadly Tom Cheshire
Sky News